[موسيقى]
مساء الخير كبر دماغك عباره يراها اسلوب
حياه تبعد الانسان عن المشاكل والضغوطات
ويراها احيانا ايضا طريقه نجاح نحو
المناصب اتخذ عنوان لاحد مؤلفاته كتبه
ومقالاته تتمحور حول تطوير الذات واحترام
له مقاطع مشهوره مصوره بين الناس لانها
تلامس همومهم وقد يرى البعض بانها اسلوب
حياه مثاليه لهم الطوق نجاه من العقد
والمشكله الدكتور خالد المنيف المؤلف
والمهتم بالتنميه البشريه وتطوير الذات في
سؤال مباشر حياك الله دكتور اهلا وسهلا
خلينا نبدا معك من المرحله الملكيه يعني
توصيف فخم اولا بهذا الشكل ولكن
انت تقول في هذه المرحله بانك اذا وصلت
اليها لن تتورط في جدال التافه لن
تستدريجك المعارك الصغيره لن تبذل جهدا
على ما لا يستحق من مواضيع
ستدرك ان التكييف او التكييف مع الظروف
واحد اهم اسباب السعاده نعم متى يمكن يوصل
للانسان للمرحله الملكيه المساله لها
علاقه بعمر
همم هي لا تتعلق بعمر بل هي عمليه تراكميه
وليست عمليه راديكاليه سريعه بتعبير
السياسيين تاتيك هكذا ولا بالمناسبه لا
احتفي باي تغيير سريع انا احتفل كثيرا
بالتغيير المتدرج ادعى للرسوخ المرحله
الملكيه هي مرحله جميله ولو ان انني انا
انا وانا من كتبته هذا المقال وصلت الى ما
كتبته الى صفحه الملائكه لكن الانسان لابد
ان يكون يعني على اثقل علاقه يكون لديه
توجه خالد اخي خالد العمر قصير وليس همه
بروفه في هذه الحياه فيجب ان تشتهر ان
تحيا ولا ان تعيش انت اجمل ما امكنك ما
امكنك والحياه وتعتمد على جودتها افكارك
ولا تعتمد بحاله من الاحوال على جوده
ظروفك وان نعطيها قليلا بس قليل من
الاهميه لكن جوده الافكار هي هي هي اللي
تعطيها الانسان والصفات اللي يصل الى هذه
المرحله خليني اسالك انت وصلت للمرحله
الملكيه
حول حول الحمى مره
ااا ادخلوا في الحما ثم اخرج منه بين اا
يعني اقبالا وادبار كما قلت شوف اهم شيء
في الحياه انه نمو العقلي اخي خالد ليس
كنبوه الجسد نمو الجسد ينمو بشكل لا ارادي
لكن الانسان لابد ان يمارس سلوكا اراديا
في التعامل مع الخبرات مع المواقف الكثير
ويمر عليه كثير من الخبرات وكثير من
المواقف لكن هناك من لا يستفيد لذلك
المرحله الملكيه تحتاج اليك ان تعمل العقل
هذا اولا امر اخر في غايه الاهميه العمر
قصير هل ستخضع لمساله التجربه والخطا لا
طبعا لذلك قضيه الاحتكاك بالعقلاء
والناضجين والحكماء والقراءه والاطلاع لا
شك انه يعجل بالوصول الى هذه المرحله من
اخر الاشياء التي توصلت اليها في هذه
المرحله ان اقبل من الناس من 60% اذا
اعطوني 60 70% اخذه ما تيسر منهم 30 انا
محللهم وهذا ايضا ينطبق على نفسي لا اطالب
ونفسي بان اعطي بنسبه 100% ابدا ولا طالب
60 70 احد مظاهر المرحله الملكيه ايضا في
المرحله الملكيه بالمناسبه خالد خلصت من
وهم السيطره انا كان جتني مرحله معينه كنت
اعتقد ان المسؤول عن كل شيء عن تغيير
الاخرين عن تغيير الطباعهم عن بعض الاشياء
التي تزعجني لا لا لا لا الان وصلت الى
مرحله فيها اعتقد يعني احسب ان فيها شيئا
من النظري انني بدات اميز او بدات يعني
اعرف دائره مسؤولياتي
في المرحله خلصت يعني
تغيير الاخرين
يسووك عندهم بعض الاشياء وبعض الطباعه
وبعض العادات وكنت اعتقد انني انا المسؤول
عنهم وكنت الومه نفسي واصل الى درجه الجلد
لكن اكتشفته مؤخرا ان ان مسؤوليه تتظل
محدوده مسؤوليتي محدوده
والله
اعتقد حتى يعني من باب التوسع واحنا حتى
حتى الرحله الطيران لو تاخرت ليش ليش ليش
ليش تاخرت يعني
لكن الحمد لله
ههه
سبع سنوات
في تغيير في النفسيه بفضل ايش بفضل تغيير
الافكار لا انت تغير حياتك الا اذا تغيرت
افكارك انشتاين له كلمه جميله دائما يتحدث
عنها وهي منهج حياه يقول ان عقلك الذي
انتج مشكله معينه بنفس المستوى من العقليه
او من الوعي مرح يحلها تحتاج الى ادوات
جديده وهذه الادوات انما تاتيك الغالب من
الافكار الجديده او او من التخلي من
الافكار القديمه طيب انت تقول اخيرا لماذا
تنتظر المرحله العمريه معينه حتى تنعم
بالمرحله الملكيه بس انا حتى بس اعرف هذه
المرحله الانسان لما يكون عايش في هذه
المرحله يعني كيف يشعر في من حوله في في
في الاوضاع اللي يعيشها يعني بانه يجب ان
يكون لا مبالي ولي ولي
في علم الاخلاق يقول دائما الفضيله
فضيلهتين احنا لا نريد ان نكون متبلدين
وجامدين او او الله
خارجين عن سر بينا لا لكن لا نريد اشخاص
يستغرقون في الامور
اني نقول والله
يتوحدون مع احيانا في بعض الامور وبعض
الاشياء همم المرحله الملكيه همم جمالها
انك ستعطي اكثر
علاقاتك ستكون افضل لانك لن تكون يعني
بذاكر العتب او اللوم او التدقيق على اخر
مرحله الملكيه معناه انك والله تجعل مساحه
معينه انت متنازل عنها وهذه الحقيقه وهذا
الحقيقه احنا احنا بشر لا ننشد حلولا
كامله في وسط غير كامل فهذه تجعلك معارك
تلاقيها
في في احيان في بعض الناس يعني خذ معارك
والله لا تقدم ولا تاخر ويرمي بكل ما لديك
الان نحن في عصر السوشل ميديا حلو انا
الان احد الاشخاص الذين لوجود في سوشي
يوم من الايام اتاتن خلف الكيبورد ويعطيك
شيئا من الكلام القاسي او النقد الجارح
هذه هذه انا لو تورطت معه
دي في ساحته زي ربما لا مو ربما الجزما
سيغلبني زين وايضا يعني مجهود شوف شوف نحن
طاقات طاقه هاديه انها توجهها لحياتك
لمشاريعك او توجهها لمثل هذه الامور ولازم
والله كل كل كل معركه ان اتوقف عنده كل
انسان لابد اتوقف عند لا لا لا في مرحله
هذه تنتقل المعارك وتنتقي بعض الاشخاص
اكون صريح معك اكون صريح معك انا لا
يشرفني ان اكون معه واحده
هذا الشخص الذي اختبا الذي يسب ويشتم ولا
تعرف من يكون زين او الشخص الذي والله
احيانا يعني يقول يهجموا عليك هجوم صارخا
وينفسه ويفر عليك
طال عمرك يهاجمك يعني ما شاء الله كل
متابعينك اراهم ايجابيات
في تغريدات في كتاباتك في دورك على
السوشيال
بشكل همم
مع السلامه لا منك لهذا طبع الحياه وهذه
الثنائيه موجوده جدا جدا وان كنتم يعني قد
ربما اقله من بعض الذين ياخذني ان انا
ناخذه في مواضيع عامه مالي والله في الذي
يتنازعوا او ينقسموا عليها الناس انا
مواضيع يا اما
الشاب يعني انت تقول مثلا انه لماذا تنتظر
مرحله عمريه معينه حتى النوم بالمرحله
الملكيه خذ خذ بها من الان فقليل من دروس
الحياه ما تاخذه بالمجان كانك تتحدث عن
الشباب ربما صحيح صحيح
لكن الشاب الشاب يجب ان يعيش حاله كفاح
حاله
تنافس حاله تجاوز للصعوبات والتحديات
والعقبات وغير من من الامور هذا بالتالي
يتنافر ربما او يتناقض مع مصطلح المرحله
الملكيه المرحله الملكيه يا صديقي لا تدعو
الى القعود ولا تدعو الى الدعاء ولا تدعوا
الى الى التجمل هي تدعو الى انك توحدها
وتكثف جهودك وتوزعها تجاهك هي هي في
جملتها
تدعو الى الى خزان طاقتك
تحافظ عليه
تحافظ عليها والاكشن هلا ليست الدعوه الى
القعود والعزال عن الحياه الحياه جمالها
في العطاء الحياه جمالها في ان يكون من
المشروع في الحياه وان تتقدم جزء كبير من
سعادتك
الذي خلى الذين يخلدون رئيس القاعدون
والذكر للانسان عمر ثاني الذكر الطيب يكون
بالعطاء وبالعمل لكن انا اقول عن طريق بس
فقط والله انت تفعل شيء من الفلتره فقط ان
تتجنب بعض المر وانت تتعامل مع بعض الامور
بطريقتين تسمح لي همم
نعود الحوار مع الدكتور خالد
اهلا بكم من جديد في سؤال مباشر ضيفي هو
الدكتور خالد المنيب في المؤلف المهتم
بالتنميه البشريه وتطويل القدرات حياك
الله دكتور اهلا وسهلا
معك لما موضوع دورات كتب التنميه البشريه
وغيرها
وانا بطرح لك سؤال واحد من الناس
عندي مشاكل ماديه مثلا
بيخلص بدايه الشهر ما تخلص عشره
اعاني من البطاله عندي مشاكل وبكل البساطه
يجيني شخص يعني
انا اسف طيب خلوني اقلب السعوديه يعني ما
هو المطلوب معرفه
وتقويه النفس
وتوجيه الاخرين في معاله يا اخي يا اخي يا
اخي التفاؤل عباده
التفاؤل عباده ان يكون المبادره يا اخي
جزء جزء من قيمه الانسان والعادات ان
يتحرك هل مطلوب يقول والله ابقى في غرفتك
او انتقي احد زوايا بيتك وابقى فيه هل هل
هذا المطلوب اعطيني منهج عملي خطوات عمليه
صحيح
شوف شوف احيانا نشوف بعض الكلمات لها دور
لها اكثر كلمه تعمل فيك اما قضيه نعطي
خطوات هذه ايش المشكله
يا اخي ما في لو اجتمع المصلحون على انسان
لا يريد ان يتحرك او يتغير والله لن يتغير
هنا الاشكاليه
ويريدها سهله
يريدها سهله تريدون تريدين لقيانا المعالي
رخيصه ولا بد دون الشهد من ابر النحل
ولولا المشقه لساد الناس كلهم والجود يفكر
هو الاقدام قطاع البعض عنده عنده لكنه
قليله صبر احداهن يوم من الايام كانت بين
زوجها ومشاكل كثيره فاعطيت والله اعطيت
خطوات يوم واحد عادت الى المستشار وقالت
ما تغير زوجها يعني الان تتكلم عن 15 سنه
كان بينها وبينهم مشاكل تريد ان تتغير
فانا اقول الاشكاليه في البعض
شوف يا اخي هل المطلوب مني اني يوضح مشاكل
انا يوم لا يمكن كنت خارج المملكه
حتى ان الدموع تتساقط زين الام في الظهر
وتحدث وانا في اوروبا
قال تسبح في اوروبا وتتكلم
هم لا يعرفون انا المطلوب انا كمتحدث انني
اقاسمكم شكواي او اقاسموه همي انا كما يا
اخي
انا ارتاح لما اسمع صوتك الدكتور خالد
وارتاح بكلام وعبارات وجميل
وفي لحظه من لحظات احس انه هذا العملاق
النائم في داخل يستيقظ نعم ولكن
لا اقدمه
ومع ذلك انا اقدمه فيها كثير من الخطوات
وفيها كثير من المنهجات وفيها كثيره من
الاستراتيجيات وفيها كثير من الخطوات
العمليه انا كمان قلت لك البعض انا اقول
البعض قد تكون احيانا نقصر في جانب معين
وانا لا لا لا لا لا اثبت الكمال لكن في
بعض احيانا فسوه قصير اهي نفسه قصير ويريد
نتائج سريعه هنا هنا الاشكاليه لكن
الانسان عمو يا اخي قد افلح من زكاها لابد
يكون انسان يتحرك لو بدي يكون عنده حرص
والاهتمام والمسؤوليه هذه المسؤولياتك انت
لما انت المسؤول عن حالك الطرف الاخر الذي
اخترته ربما يقدم لك 10% 15% وهي طريق وهي
رحله لا تتوقع تغيرا سريعا حضرت الدوره لا
ممكن تحرك فيه كلام ممكن تكون البدايه من
هذا المتحدث او من هذا المدرب او من هذا
الكتاب لكن لا الانسان ينشدون البشر عموما
ينشدون تغييرها لا لا لا لا لو انا خالد
اخي خالد الذي ياتي سريعا يده سريعا
الذي يذهب عن دائما دائما
احدهم تكلم عن كتب التنميه البشريه انا لا
اشكاليه يا اخي انا ولا اقول كل فيها من
الاخطاء وفيها من المبالغهات وفيها من
المثاليات وفيه وفيها لكن
الخلاف بيني وبين من لديه مثل هذا الطرح
انه يؤمن هل قرات كل الكتب الان التعميم
الان يحتاج منك الى انت تاخذ عينه مناسبه
هل قرات كل الكتب طيب تعال انت انت الان
حذرته من كتب معينه من ماذا ما هي النقطه
ما هي الفكره التي حذرتها منه ولماذا اما
الكلام بشكل عمومي وهكذا الله يكفي كتب
كثيره نفعل الله بها وانا من خلال انك
نافع الله بها وغيرت اشخاص نقلتهم من حاله
الى حاله
والله
تغيرت حياتهم يعني
والله نعم الله علي لا تعدوا ولا تحزن لكن
الامر الذي يجعلني احلق في السماء انني
باحدهم يقول والله خالد انها كلمه او
مقاله لا القي لها حسابا انا متشبع من
هواء كنت اعتقد ان الناس يعني قد لايتات
فاذ بها تؤثر تحرك حلقه تحرك على الاقل
تكون البذره الاولى زين وهذا امر الله
شكله شكل الحمد لله من نعم الله عليه ومن
نعم الله على وشوف اسال الله تعالى اسال
الله تعالى ان يخلص لي ولكن اللهم امين
كبر دماغك ايش علاقتها بانه ممكن ان تحضر
بالمناصب وتفوز بالفرص اذا كبرت العرب لا
تسود الاحمق
لا تجعله سيدا
الاحنف ابن القيسي بني تميم كان اذا غضبا
الاحنف غضب معه يقولون 100,000 سيف لا
يسالونه في غضب لذلك جزء من من من من
الشخصيه
وتكلمت عنه كثيرا مرارا وتكرارا يا اخي في
بعض الامور والله لا تستحق منك هذه الغضب
النظريه وهذا الانفعال وهذا التوتر وهذا
نقول تعطيل تعطيل الحياه واحيانا ايلان من
حولنا على امره كبر دماغك يا اخي ههه كثير
كثير من حالات لا تستاهل لا تستحق وانا
مطنش داعش زي ما بيقولوا نفس الشيء خيارات
ما عندك خيرات
خالد محدودين نحن في الوقت وفي القدره وفي
وفي نقول والله ال- ال- عموما البشر
محدودين في عندهم عندهم طابع المحدوديه
فذلك انت يعني
الامور كانك تطنش كانك لم تسمع وكانك لم
ترى في بعض الامور يا اخي متجه كثيرا احبك
في القضيه زيدان
ليش تركز على هذا الموضوع هي عباره تتردد
كثيره يعني والكل يتحدث عنها ليش تركز
عليه يا دكتور قبل ان اتكلم واتحدث عنها
وانا والله اتمنى
المسؤولين في وزاره التعليم ان يجعلون
الذكاء العاطفي منهجنا والله
لسه بالطلاق والسجون ستخف والعلاقات
الدكتور
احكي لك مشهدا وقل لي اذا كان واجهك في
حياتك اولا ما سبق نقابلت انسان معدلاته
عاليه وتخصصه دقيق
وما شاء الله تبارك الله يملك القدره
عقليه عاليه لكنه بالمصطلح هذه بتر
وغثيث وصعب وممل ولا احد يقدر يتعايش معه
هذا عنده الايكي واللي يسمى حاصل الذكاء
عالي الذكاء العقلي قدرات العقليه
الاجتماعيه
ولا موظفا جيدا ولا صديقا صحيحا ما تمكنه
جزء كبير من من هؤلاء في في اماكن محدوده
المعول عليها الان بحسب بعض الدراسات 75
الى 80% مما انت عليه الان من راح وسعاده
ونجاح واو واو حتى في كل مناحي الحياه
يعتمد على ذكائك العاطفي الذكاء العاطفي
20 15
بين الذكاء العاطفي الذكيا عاطفيا لو ان
تكون عاطفيا او رومانسيه او رومانسيه
حب
بليه غلط
على فهم مشاعرك وادارتها معناها مختلف ترى
تماما عن مساله الانسان العاطفي العاطفيه
ولا الدفاع في العاطفيه او الشحه العاطفه
كلها غلط لكن ذكاء العاطف على فهم مشاعرك
وادارتها وفهم مشاعر الاخرين وايضا
التعامل معها يعني انا اقول شوف من من
اعطيك شيء من مكونات الذره الوعي بالذات
البشروا في جملتهم يعني عندهم قدره على ان
يعرفوا تفاصيل الاخرين لكنه لو عن نفسه
سالت عن نفسه ما يعرف نفسه ما يعرف نفس
الوعي بذات انت تعرف نفسك ولا لا يا اخي
بعض الناس يمارس اخطاء بشكل يومي فيها
ايذاء وفيها جرح وفيها اعتداء وفيها اشياء
في ضد مصلحتي لكن غير واعي فيها يقول
كلمات احيانا احيانا لا يقول لكنه غير
واعي فيها واسهر انواع الوعي ليس الوعي
الوعي بالسلوك ممكن
الوعي بالمشاعر الى اخطر انواع الوحي
الوحي بالافكار
احنا في بعض الناس عنده افكار تشاميه
احيانا عنده افكار يعني
متمسك بالماضي احيانا عنده افكار تجاه
المستقبل تشاؤميه وكارثيه لذلك الوعي
بالذات قيمه عاليه ايضا وعيك بمشاعرك انت
كيف ستسيطر على مشاعر وانت لا تعرفها
تسميه المشاعر مهمه ان تسمي مشاعرك وان
تعرف اثرها على الاخرين لماذا قال الحبيب
اللهم صل وسلم عليه لا يقضي القاضي حين
يقضي وهو غضبان لان الغضبان في حاله معينه
لا يستطيع لا يعني لا يستطيع معها ان
يوفقها الى الحكم لذلك هذا والحديث عن
الذكاء العاطفي حديث ذو سجون وقد سالتني
عن عظيم يعطيك حاجه مهمه الذكاء العاطفي
ليس فضل معرفه ولا ترى فكري بل هو غروره
من ضرورات الحياه همم دكتور همم الملل
ايضا يمكن من الاشياء اللي يمر فيها
الانسان وخاصه كثير همم
حياته اليوميه كانت ممكن الانسان يواجه
هذه اول
ههه هذا قضيه مهمه ترى مو لازم كل لحظه
ولا ولا
تتميز الاشياء يا اخي يا اخي من الاشياء
المهمه في علم النفس الايجابي ما يسمى بين
تقبل بعض الامور ومنها الملل الملل هي
حياتك اليوم والله فيها شيء من الفرحه
وفيها شيء من البهجه بكره اقل شوي بعده
اقل شوي تقبل وجود الملل وخلينا يعطيك
حاجه على الملل ما الذي يسبب الملل سبحان
الله النفس التي لا تريد يوميا تجديد
اعطيك حاجه مهمه يعطيك يعني يوم من الايام
احدهم يقول لك اولادي ما شاء الله تعالى
وبركاته يعني كثير السفر مثلا من سنوات
فقل حسين احساسنا وهذا خطا الاعتماد وفي
حياتك على امر ما تتمحور عليه سعادتك خطا
من الاشياء الجميله التي انا انا شخصيا
امارسها لكي اقطع احيانا بعض حالات او
اخفف منها لا انتظر شيء جديد بل انني
استثمر ما لدي في بعض الاشياء كثيره في
حياتنا الان لم تستثمر بشكل جيد ايضا من
الاشياء تقطع الحاله النفسيه وحاله الملل
وتعطيك شويه روح في حياتك يا اخي نعمه
نعمه الامتنان وهي من النعم والمهارات انا
اقول شبه المفقوده ودائما بعض الناس اذا
سالناها خالد قال لنا كيف حالك ايش امور
قال والله الامور على حالها وانا يعني
خرجتو بامر بالنسبه لي في غايه الاهميه
الحمد لله كثير الاشياء المتغيرت ارتبكت
الحياه طيب همم اختم بسؤال سريع ان شاء
الله همم حوالي 88,000 مشترك في قناتك
يوتيوب ما شاء الله تبارك الله نعم 64,000
متابع في انستغرام 480.000 متابع في تويتر
22,000 معجب بصفحتك في فيسبوك ولك وجود
كبير في سناب شات مدري كم الرقم
800,000 ما شاء الله تبارك
ليش الناس يتوجه
الى خالد الدكتور خالد منيف وغيره من
الناس المهتمين بالتطوير الذات والتنميه
البشريه هو غيرها من الامور يعني مثلا كان
في في برنامج 8 في البوات كاست الحزام
يعتقد قال نحقق رقم 1,000,000
مقارنه بمقابلات مهمه تتعلق بحياه الناس
البعض يقول بانو الناس
تهو اليوم البعد عن واقعها وحياتها
والاتجاه نحو الخيال والاحلام
والمدينه الفاضله والافلاطونيه
هذه الصفات القبشه ذكرتها في الشخص الملكي
ههه
يعني يختلف معك في اننا نحس نشعر بشيء من
الغضن هناك بعض المحتويات زين ارقامها
فلكيه جدا لكن في المقابله لبعض
الوصايا الجميله في تعاملات الحياه في
النظر الى مستقبليه في التعامل مع الماضي
الان حرفيا في تعب تسارع الاحداث كبيره
وكل مكان هذا هذا الانحياز الجيد
لمثل هذه الامور وانا ما اتكلم قد يكون ها
تطبطب عليهم
كلمه طيبه كلمه طيبه قصه هادفه زين معاني
جميله في الحياه تجربه شخصيه زين تغير
الانسان دائما ويقول لمن له في هذا
الاتجاه لا تحقرناه من المعروف شيء والان
والتواجد المحتوى الهادف الان اعتبره وفرض
عين فرض عين هل هل مد هائل همم
تحتاج الامثالهم اشكرك قدمته لجرعه كبيره
من التفاؤل دكتور
يكفي حضوري معك وابتسامتك العذراء وروحك
الطيبه
دكتور خالد المنيف المهتم والمهل ايضا فيه
تطوير الذات
والتنميه البشريه يعني هذه الحلقه من سؤال
مباشر
على تويتر فيسبوك يوتيوب
والمشاهده والاستماع لهذه الحلقه على شاهد
على العربيه
[موسيقى]